la gente
buenos buenos días a todos
seguramente todos alguna vez nos hemos
sentido un poco perdidos en nuestro
viaje por el tiempo el tiempo es un poco
incluso san agustín solo podría
explicarlo o solo podía entenderlo o
solo podría acercarse a saber que era el
tiempo en el caso de que no tuviera que
hablar de lo que no tuviera que
explicarlo
a mí me gustaría hoy hablar de ese
camino que nos puede sacar de ese
laberinto y no es fácil no es fácil
salir de ese laberinto no es fácil salir
de ese camino como lo voy a hacer bueno
voy a hacer de distintas maneras en
primer lugar lo que voy a intentar es
mirar hacia el futuro y entonces tratar
de explorar el futuro de la humanidad y
por otro lado voy a tratar de mirar al
pasado tratando de estudiar ciertas
historias antiguas del lejano oriente la
idea es tratar de recorrer ese camino
que hace el pasado para transformarse en
futuro pero aunque parezca paradójico y
como han presentado antes de lo que ya
les quiero hablar por tanto es del
futuro del pasado
la idea es merece el pasado un futuro o
en otras palabras merece la pena
construir una tradición entendiendo por
tradición justamente esa parte del
pasado que merece un futuro
pues bien
el futuro de la humanidad yo creo que es
algo que nos preocupa a todos
de hecho la célebre y la prestigiosa
universidad de oxford ha creado un
instituto dedicado justamente a esa
cuestión y no es azaroso que surjan
estas iniciativas parece que la
humanidad está en un momento crítico
como muestra un estudio que ha sido
publicado recientemente por 14 autores
provenientes de tres instituciones
universitarias distintas de siete países
en el que se analiza precisamente las
trayectorias que a largo plazo pudiera
seguir la civilización humana como
pueden ver ahí alguna de esas
trayectorias podrían acabar en la
extinción y no es difícil imaginar como
guerra nuclear el choque con un
meteorito efectos devastadores de un
posible cambio climático inteligencia
artificial descontrolada pandemias o
cualquier combinación de todas ellas
pero no hace falta ponerse tan negativo
podríamos ir a otro extremo ser
positivos y pensar en hacer ciencia
ficción dura por ejemplo las
nanotecnologías podrían propiciar lo que
se ha denominado fabricación de
precisión atómica eso nos permitiría
fabricar prácticamente cualquier cosa y
no
en un estado de anuncia radical en ese
estado pues yo que sé cosas como la
escasez de recursos la cura de
enfermedades todas estas cosas ya no
serían un problema nunca más y luego
está la inteligencia artificial si
llegamos a ese punto en el que los
algoritmos puedan mejorar por turismos
recursiva mente entraríamos en lo que se
ha denominado una singularidad
tecnológica es decir un punto en el que
esas funciones exponenciales de ahí se
transformarían en temas de de irak
serían verticales y por lo tanto
tendríamos una explosión de inteligencia
que además debería ser controlada por
urgencia humana mucho menos mucho menos
capaz y eso probablemente daría lugar a
lo que algunos autores han denominado
una post humanidad es decir una
civilización de agentes cognitivos post
humanos con unas capacidades y unos
intereses muy distintos probablemente de
los seres humanos actuales por tanto la
pregunta ya no es qué podemos hacer
porque es que vamos a poder comunicarse
en todo la pregunta es que podemos hacer
o que debemos hacer para poder progresar
adecuadamente por el tiempo
pues bien de ya que me gustaría
transmitirles en esta charla es que del
mismo modo que los puntos cardinales
para orientarnos en el espacio algo así
como que necesitamos un norte aunque
queramos ir al sur del mismo modo
necesitamos puntos cardinales para
orientarnos en el tiempo y que ese un
punto bueno de anclaje es la tradición
algo así como que necesitamos el pasado
para poder inseguros hacia el futuro
mi interés por la tradición se despertó
con mis lecturas con mis lecturas
infantiles yo vivía en un barrio
puro anodino y me gustaba evadirme
leyendo historias de reyes 13 brujos
cosas así y siempre me impactaba el
poder que tenía la palabra amparada por
la tradición de la fascinante alguien
era un villano pero de repente un rey
decía te nombró caballero y ese hombre
se levantaba investido de dignidad aquel
otro era un vil pecador pero venía un
sacerdote y decía te perdono tus pecados
y ese hombre ya estaba habilitado para
entrar en el reino de los cielos tanto
me interesó que muy pronto empecé a
estudiar artes marciales tradicionales
les confieso que también empecé a
estudiar karate porque en mi barrio los
niños que leían de sacerdotes y reyes
pues muy bien vistos no estaban pero en
cualquier caso en cuanto pude viaje a
okinawa para entrenar con los maestros
que habían sido los herederos de una
tradición milenaria tradición
etimológicamente significa entrega y
aquí tienen una imagen que refleja la
entrega de un cierto saber que llegó a
mí a partir de cinco generaciones
conocidas al menos arriba de todo tiene
al maestro yuriko en china que es con
quien fue a entrenar el maestro gigaba
una canción que está un poquito más
abajo
el maestro gigaba una canción entregó
ese saber al maestro soy un millón
tenemos esto soy un millón y entre nueve
sin saber al maestro miyazato y chi y el
que está al final del todo aunque no se
lo crean soy yo hace 20 años en okinawa
tratando de aprender todo lo que podía
de millas datos en 6
y la verdad es que los primeros días de
entrenamiento en okinawa no fueron
fáciles
el maestro solamente pasaba a mi lado y
me decía keiko y luego señalándose al
decía sensei
yo sabía que keiko significaba entrenar
entrenamiento y que sensei significaba
maestro así que supuse que lo que tenía
que hacer es entrenar más duro siguiendo
sus instrucciones que por cierto eran
ninguna pero yo por más que me esforzaba
y sudaba el maestro sólo pasaba y decía
que dijo en 6
en fin el día un día desesperado ya el
maestro al ver mi desesperación porque
no entendía nada cogió una cartulina y
escribió eso
keiko y sensei pero luego hizo esto y
fue entonces cuando me di cuenta digo lo
que tengo que hacer es analizar los
kanjis que componen las palabras así que
cuando salí de la clase corrí a ver a mi
amigo macchi con ak que me ayudaba con
el japonés y le dije qué significa esto
y ella me reveló el significado oculto
de las palabras que me dijo significa
con de edad estudiar qué significa
antiguo pasado
así que las artes marciales
tradicionales entrenar no era repetir
como yo estaba haciendo entrenar era
considerar el pasado en cada gesto para
proyectarlo al futuro se en continuaba
mágico significa previo anterior 6
significa nacer vida así que en las
artes marciales tradicionales el sensei
y el maestro lo es porque han nacido
antes que tú y ha recorrido ya el camino
que tú tienes que recorrer otra vez el
pasado guiándonos hacia el futuro
profundo a mí esto me tranquilicé un
tiempo y aprendí más pero estaba
inquieto y estaba inquieto porque no era
capaz de comprender las técnicas
artificiales que me hacía a ser mi
maestro era muy artificial y desde luego
preguntar al maestro no es una opción en
un rollo de carne tradicional y en mi
barrio se peleaba de otra manera no
peleábamos así así que el maestro dio
ver mi cara de estupefacción me llamó y
me llevó al parque matsuyama este tan
bonito que están aquí y esa imagen que
hay allá abajo es un icono de tradición
es un recuerdo a su maestro y al maestro
de su maestro y estando allí me sentó y
me dijo
maestro lírico hablaba así mi maestro
maestro el único enseñó una historia
maestro giba ona maestro giga una enseña
maestro millán y para eso mira y enseña
a mí yo hoy te la cuento a ti escucha y
aprende y me contó una historia rica en
detalles pero que yo tengo que resumir
aquí así el joven tchenguiz quería
convertirse en el mejor arquero de china
para eso fue a visitar a un anciano
maestro cuyas proezas con el arco eran
legendarias se decía que era el mejor
arquero de todos los tiempos cuando lo
encontró dejó su arco sobre la mesa y le
dijo maestro quiero aprender de ti el
maestro dijo muy bien pero tengo que
hacer una pregunta primero podrías
decirme el nombre y la función de ese
objeto que has dejado sobre la mesa y
que me resulta familiar
como pueden suponer la historia me
conmocionó el arco no es importante el
argos es importante las técnicas que me
enseñaba el maestro no es importante lo
que es importante es que el
entrenamiento tradicional genera
intangibles en el practicante a partir
de elementos tangibles como es el arco
que son del todo contingentes de hecho
quizá lo necesario sea olvidarlos y
conste que estas ideas esas ideas no son
veleidades o cosas lucubraciones propias
de la filosofía oriental existen datos
experimentales que demuestran que esto
es así por ejemplo en un estudio
reciente publicado en 'nature
communications' rico en detalles también
como sugiere esta transparencia pero que
yo tengo que resumir aquí se pone de
manifiesto que cuando se aumenta la
neurogénesis del hipocampo se produce el
olvido necesario para posibilitar la
codificación de ciertos contenidos
nuevos a veces olvidar es bueno las
técnicas que no comprendía estaban
hechas precisamente para ser olvidadas y
esto me tranquilizo un tiempo pero yo
seguía un poco inquieto porque está muy
bien que ciertas cosas tangibles una
dentición presentan
pero lo que yo quería es que luego lo
intangible que estaba en mí pudiera
volver al mundo de forma tangible el
maestro movido de ver mi cara de
preocupación me volvió a llevar al
parque y matsuyama volvió a invocar la
transición volvió a decírmelo de escucha
y aprende y me contó otra historia la
siguiente
el mejor calígrafo de su show por una
cuestión de honor tuvo que aceptar un
reto a muerte con el mejor del resto de
la provincia de general el calígrafo era
muy muy buen calígrafo pero no tenía ni
idea de manejar la espada así que fue a
ver a un amigo suyo maestro del arte de
la espada para que le enseñara al menos
a desenfundar con dignidad y poder así
morir honorablemente su amigo le dijo no
puedo enseñarte nada no hay tiempo un
consejo solamente el día del combate de
desenvaina tu espada con la misma
actitud con la que trazas tus calles
sobre el pergamino el día del combate
así lo hizo el calígrafo y cuando debió
el guerrero cayó de rodillas y le dijo
en verdad debe ser el más grande maestro
del arte de la espada a nadie había
visto desenfundar con esa subida y
armonía no soy digno de pelear contigo
disponde mi vida como creas conveniente
de nuevo la historia me impactó
sobremanera
de alguna manera el círculo se había
cerrado y mis preguntas estaban
respondidas en excepto los intangibles
que había puesto de entrenamiento
tradicional podrían volverse tangibles
de hecho habían enseñado al maestro
calígrafo las dos cosas más importantes
que se pueden enseñar a vivir y a morir
iluminados ya tras nuestro viaje a
okinawa podemos volver a nuestras
preguntas acerca del futuro de la
humanidad de nuestra civilización
y digo inquietudes porque no no tenemos
por qué adoptar una visión panglossiano
según la cual el progreso nos va a
llevar a lugares deseables no estoy
pensando en escenarios de extinción pero
se puede pensar ya en escenarios de
evolución distópicos que son cuando
menos imaginables
por ejemplo nick bostróm el director del
instituto de oxford al que aludía al
principio ha señalado que la tecnología
podría propiciar dos cosas una implantar
mentes humanas en máquinas dos generar
prótesis cognitivas para esas mentes en
este escenario no sería raro pensar que
los agentes cognitivos más exitosos es
decir los que se acabarían replicando
generarán finalmente arquitecturas
cognitivas que nada se parecieran a las
del ser humano y por lo tanto crearon
una civilización es tuberías que
estuviera exenta de valores humanos que
hoy consideramos irrenunciables y si
esto les parece ciencia ficción
inverosímil esa cuando tal que algunas
cosas ya están pasando como nos han
dicho ya están aquí ya están aquí por
ejemplo facebook se puso a la tarea de
desarrollar algoritmos de inteligencia
artificial para crear lo que ellos
denominan comunidades significativas
ingeniería social donde los algoritmos
guían como se agrupan las personas y la
cosa tuvo éxito 400 millones de personas
están en esas comunidades significativas
y está muy bien pero combinarlos es
hablar sobre el precio que estamos
pagando una muy claro nos dimos cuenta
cuando nos enteramos que terceros
utilizaron la información de facebook
para alterar estados de opinión y
probablemente procesos electorales otro
cómo se está desdibujando la línea entre
lo virtual y lo real bueno eso está muy
claro por ejemplo en proyectos como
google glass o como pokemon go conviene
recordar que tenemos un cuerpo y que el
cuerpo es una cosa muy útil como decía
woody allen cuando uno quiere darse un
masaje
por tanto ha llegado el momento de
pensar cómo tomar decisiones sobre cómo
vamos a avanzar al futuro quizá como
ilustraba mi entrenamiento en okinawa y
como ilustra esta imagen el pasado
sea un buen punto de partida yo estoy en
el presente si quiero ir hacia el futuro
no sé qué hacer quién soy que quiero soy
verde soy rojo soy morado no tengo ni
idea pero a mí está el pasado y descubro
que lo que yo soy se ha constituido a
partir de la trayectoria marcada por la
línea roja pues cuando vuelvo a mirar al
futuro la cosa está clara al menos en lo
que no tengo que hacer nivel de ánimo
nada ya veremos qué hago con el rojo por
tanto el pasado proporciona condiciones
necesarias pero no suficientes para
saber qué hacer y por tanto defender la
tradición es compatible con descender el
progreso transición no es repetir lo que
hicieron los antiguos es seguir buscando
lo que ellos buscaban como dijo ya un
pacto japonés hace más de 300 años y
este día es tan importante que me
gustaría pedirles que me acompañaran por
última vez al parque matsuyama para que
les cuente una última y breve historia
un alumno de karate quería fundar su
propia escuela el maestro le dijo no
tienes mi permiso tu técnica se parece a
la mía en un 50% el alumno le dijo
maestro tiene que parecerse en un cien
por cien dije no no tiene que parecerse
en absoluto
me contó esta historia el maestro
miyazato
me contó alguna de las anteriores
a estas alturas ya deberíamos saber que
no hay que mirar el arco lo importante
es la flecha la flecha que ya no está la
flecha del tiempo que sigue su camino
inexorable hacia el futuro no estoy
prejuzgando como tiene que ser ese
futuro no estoy prejuzgando tampoco que
significará ser humano en ese futuro
solamente digo que no podemos dejarnos
arrastrar por la intensidad del progreso
inercia muchas veces sesgada por los
intereses de unos pocos y no siempre
buenos lo que digo es que hay que tomar
decisiones y que más vale tomarlas como
los agentes racionales y morales que
somos
hoy coaching
aprende de lo antiguo para comprender lo
nuevo si el futuro está constituido con
larga masa del pasado seguro que será un
sitio más habitable para el hombre como
me enseñó mi maestro y con esto ya les
dejo no se trata de preservar las
cenizas se trata de mantener viva la
llama muchas gracias
[Aplausos]